dans moins d'un an les Yvelines vont
accueillir des épreuves des Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 la ville de
Versailles va recevoir les épreuves
d'équitation de pareil équitation et de
pentathlon moderne dans le parc du
château la ville royale verra aussi
passer les cours du marathon ainsi que
les cyclistes sur route une épreuve qui
passera aussi par saint-jean-en-laye la
plaine de Versailles la vallée de
Chevreuse et le vélo Drôme national de
50 ans en Yvelines le vélodrome national
qui accueillera aussi les épreuves de
cyclisme surpissent et de parasyclisme
sur son site l'année prochaine devant
5000 spectateurs à une centaine de
mètres du Vélodrome les courses de BMX
Race seront organisées sous ce toit avec
les meilleurs riders de la planète
toujours sur 50 ans en Yvelines le Golf
National recevra les épreuves golfiques
6 ans seulement après la Ryder Cup 2018
une première mondiale pour un parcours
de golf enfin la colline d'Élancourt
c'est 230 mètres d'altitude accueillera
les épreuves de VTT en 2024 sur un site
qui s'annonce difficile pour les
concurrents il reste maintenant moins
d'un an différents sites pour se
préparer pour cet événement planétaire
la cérémonie d'ouverture est programmée
le vendredi 26 juillet sur la scène et
les premières médailles ailles seront
délivrées dès le 27 juillet